حيث قال المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه رفع الجروسي ان طهران وافقت
على السماح للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
بالمضي في اجراءات المراقبه والتحقق
الاضافي
في مؤتمر صحفي عقب اجتماع مجلس محافظي
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه ان هناك
فرصه جديه فيما يتعلق بايران ولكنه قال
انه لا يمكنه ضمان اي شيء
كان هناك تبادل للاراء ولم نكن متفقين على
كل شيء ولكن تمكنا من اقناع ايران بالحاجه
للتحقق من زياده نسب التحصيل وكذلك فيما
يخص المراقبه
الذي بدا اليوم ويستمر لعده ايام بعد
زياره غراس الى ايران والتزامن مع جوله
لوزير الدفاع الامريكي في الشرق الاوسط
يجري خلالها مباحثات بشان البرنامج النووي
الايراني
من داخل مقر الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه في فيينا مراسل الجزيره محمد
البقالي ضعنا في صوره ما تم بحثه اليوم
محمد في هذه الاجتماعات
وما الاجواء والانطباعات خصوصا بعد زياره
غراسي الى طهران وتصريحاته الاخيره
الحقيقه ان العنوان الرئيسي لاجتماعات
اليوم ولحديث قروصي هو التهدئه او في الحد
الادنى تجنب التصعيد من خلال التركيز على
ان مرحله جديده قد فتحت او يمكن ان تفتح
في العلاقه مع ايران وفقا لحديث جروسي
ثلاث نقاط رئيسيه
ركز عليها الاتجاه اولا قال بان ايران
مستعده للتعاون مع الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه بشان مراقبه برنامجها النووي
والتحقق من سلميته وفقا للاتفاق الذي تم
التوصل اليه خلال الزياره الاخيره طبعا
تفاصيل هذا الاتفاق هي متروكه للفرق
التقنيه التي ستزور ايران قريبا ثانيا كان
غروسيا حريصا على التاكيد على ان زيارته
الى طهران هذه المره كانت نتائجها مختلفه
عن الزيارات السابقه لماذا لانه قال ان
اللقاء هذه المره كان مع الرئيسي نفسه
لاول مره وبشكل مطول ثم اكد بان تم التوصل
الى توافق بش وصول او تعزيز مراقبه
المفتشين لمنشاه فوندو التي تثير مخاوف
اكثر من غيرها بالنظر الى انه يتم فيها
تخصيب اليورانيوم بنسبه 60 في المئه وفيها
وجدت العينات التي تقول الوكاله انها
اليورانيوم مخصب بنسبه قريبه من 84% اي
اقل قليلا من نسبه 90% المطلوبه لتصنيع
قنبله نوويه اذا كانت الكميه كافيه ثالثا
او النقطه الثالثه الرئيسيه هو رغم كل هذه
الاشارات المتفائله قال بانه ليست لديه
ضمانات ولا يمكن ان يضمن اي شيء ثم قال
انه لا توجد قائمه مفصله بالاماكن التي
تعتزم الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
زيارتها في ايران ولا تواريخ محدده بعد
للقيام بذلك ماذا يعني كل هذا يعني ان
اجتماعات المجلس ستتم الان تحت سقف
التهدئه وليس تحت سقف التصعيد
هذا الخطاب في مجمله هو خطاب تهدئه
والزياره في الحقيقه مكنت الجميع من كسب
مزيد من الوقت للبحث عنه عن حلول بعيدا عن
التصعيد التجارب السابقه تقول هنا في مقر
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه ان التصعيد
من قبل الوكاله او من قبل الدول الغربيه
تجاه ايران يعني بالضروره تصعيدا من قبل
ايران والنتيجه بالنسبه للوكاله وبالنسبه
للدول الغربيه ان طهران حققت تقدما في
برنامجها النووي خلال فتره الانسحاب
الامريكي ما لم تحققه من قبل وهذا الامر
هو الذي عبر عنه بشكل واضح مساعد وزير
الدفاع الامريكي امام الكونجرس الذي قال
انه عند الانسحاب من الاتفاق النووي كان
بامكان ايران الوصول الى صنع مواد القنبله
النوويه خلال 12 شهرا الان اصبح بامكانها
فعل ذلك خلال 12 اسبوعا ثم يعني بشكل
مباشر او ينعكس بشكل مباشر على هذا
الاجتماع ان احتمالات صدور قرار يدين
ايران خلال هذا الاجتماع اصبحت اضعف او
ضعيفه جدا من جهه لان موقف الوكاله ايجابي
ثم لان المعلومات الاخرى الصادره تقول ان
الامريكيين مترددون بشان ادانه ايران في
هذا المجلس وعاده الاوروبيون لا يذهبون
بعيدا في مثل هذه القرارات بدون دعم
امريكي شكرا لك محمد البقالي من مقر
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه في فيينا